ein abend willkommen zu zdf heute live
vladimir putin hat nicht nur in der
ukraine einen furchtbaren krieg
angefangen er ist auch gerade dabei eine
gewaltige hungerkrise auszulösen denn
die ukraine ist einer der grössten
getreide lieferanten weltweit und
russland blockiert diese lieferungen
seit mehr als drei monaten
das könnte nach angaben der vereinten
nationen 1,4 milliarden menschen
betreffen es braucht präsident putin
hunger als waffe schickt uns eure fragen
eure kommentare das macht ihr am besten
per mail oder schreibt sie einfach in
die kommentarspalten rein wir reden
unter anderem gleich mit dem militär
ökonomen markus kolb der uns unter
anderem erklären wird welche strategie
dahinter stecken könnte und wir sprechen
jetzt mit unserem reporter johannes hano
in odessa und mit alissa jung in lembeck
guten abend
johannes lasst uns bitte bei dir
beginnen du bist in odessa das ist der
hauptumschlagplatz für waren exporte und
importe im land und der ist seit wochen
blockiert wir müssen uns diese situation
vor ort vorstellen
also russland hat relativ simulieren des
krieges klargemacht dass man den sieben
beherrschen will das muss man auch leben
beherrschen man hat raketen abgeschossen
besser wäre selbst gesehen sind dann
immer waffen gelandet sondern sie noch
bei den bürgern hinter den häusern
gelandet also so zielgenau war das nicht
aber man hat die helfen rundum vermied
man hat kriegsschiffe draußen vor dem
meer
lieferungen zu blockieren der
relativ kompliziert
wo ich kann mich selbst praktisch ganz
musik drauf
das ist schlecht ich würde vorschlagen
projekt das im hintergrund weil es
spricht natürlich schwierig wenn wir uns
nicht richtig gut hören kannst haben wir
haben ein paar zahlen vorbereitet die
meine kollegin laura cosinus
zusammengestellt hat zudem problemen die
die dimensionen noch einmal deutlich
machen vielleicht für münsters sogar
schon
weizen aus der ukraine oder russland
seit beginn der russischen invasion ist
er knapp ein problem vor allem für
afrika und den nahen osten
denn viele der länder importieren den
großteil ihres weizens von dort weizen
im wert von 3,7 milliarden dollar so
viel importierte afrika in den jahren
2018 bis 2020 aus russland zusätzlich
weizen im wert von 1,4 milliarden dollar
aus der ukraine
damit kommen 44 prozent der
afrikanischen weizen importe aus den
beiden ländern
einige der afrikanischen länder sind
extrem abhängig von den beiden
weizenexporteur ein beispiel somalia ein
drittel der somalischen weizenexporte
kommt aus der ukraine zwei drittel aus
russland durch den krieg bleiben die
weizen lieferungen aus eine humanitäre
katastrophe
und auch in ägypten ist die abhängigkeit
von weizen aus den beiden ländern groß
mehr als 80 prozent kommt hier aus
russland und der ukraine
damit es ist das wichtigste abnehmerland
für weizen und andere getreidearten der
ukraine allein 2020 importierte gibt
mehr als drei millionen tonnen von dort
und zusätzlich mehr als acht millionen
tonnen aus russland die russische
invasion ein krieg der weit mehr als nur
europa beschäftigt laut den vereinten
nationen könnten bald 1,4 milliarden
menschen von nahrungsmittelknappheit
betroffen sein eine der schlimmsten
hungerkrisen die es je gab
wir sprechen mit johannes hano in odessa
und alissa jung in lembeck johannes hat
gerade noch ein bisschen schwierigkeiten
mit der leitung deshalb mal zu die
rallyes ich hoffe dass wir nicht besser
hören kannst du stehst in lemberg in der
nähe der polnischen grenze
man dort getreide aus dem land heraus zu
bringen über den seeweg der straße nicht
da natürlich jetzt der seeweg über den
aber das meiste getreide hier raus
gekommen ist nicht mehr funktioniert
versucht man das jetzt hier über die
züge natürlich über die schiene und auch
via lkw aber man muss sich das auch mal
so vorstellen der große große teil des
betreibers der ukraine ist also immer
über den seeweg rausgegangen ein bauer
mit dem ich heute gesprochen habe er hat
dass man ausgerechnet der meinte sie
haben so viel getreide hier was
theoretisch raus könnte raus muss sie
könnten einen zug von berlin bis nach
tokio alle griffeln also so viel
getreide ist hier und jetzt höre ich
johannes mit euch hin jetzt höre ich mit
johannes der genauere blick tonprobleme
versucht zu lösen aber ich würde euch
jetzt mal weiter berichten was das
problem ist also sie versuchen jetzt
über züge und über die lkws das getreide
hier raus zu bekommen aber da gibt es
diverse probleme denn es fängt schon
damit an dass jetzt aktuell es sich
einfach staudt an der grenze das ist das
nadel also an den ganzen grenzen zu den
anliegenden ländern wo man ja
theoretisch mit den lkws raus könnte da
staut sich lkw an lkw weil das zu
langsam geht die logistik funktioniert
da nicht richtig an diesem check points
und das dauert sehr lange weil der
werden verschiedene kontrollen
durchgeführt so besagt es beispielsweise
die regel in polen da gibt es also eine
veterinär kontrolle damit auf
salmonellen beispielsweise kontrolliert
und eine pflanzenschutz kontrolle und
das dauert zu lange das braucht zu viel
zeit und deswegen staut es sich dass es
ein problem ein anderes ist aber
natürlich auch deshalb wahrscheinlich
viele von euch schon mitbekommen die
spritpreise hier im land sind natürlich
enorm hoch und das heißt also mit lkws
so viele tonnen getreide hier raus zu
bekommen das steht natürlich auch nicht
wirklich in dem verhältnis zu den
spritpreisen teilweise noch dazu gibt es
zu wenige fahrer die in die ukraine rein
wollen oder aus der ukraine raus kennt
das ist auch ein problem und dann gibt
es auch noch natürlich diverse probleme
mit den zügen weil ich hab's
angesprochen lkw oder zug das wären die
möglichkeiten und beim zug gibt es zum
beispiel das problem dass die arbeiten
hier andere sind das heißt also die
breite der schienen die es in der
ukraine in der andere als in
angrenzenden ländern das heißt das
getreide was hier raus möchte mit dem
zug musste umgeladen werden muss
umgeladen werden in andere züge um
weiterfahren zu können und auch da fehlt
es an personal an logistik und das ist
natürlich hier ganz entscheidende
deshalb kommt es zu einem massiven stau
und das getreide steckt ihr fest
du bist vor einigen tagen in die ukraine
eingereist hast dort selber an der
grenze den rückstau erlebt wie müssen
wir uns das vorstellen
wir sind über einen grenzpunkt rein über
den nur lkw über den pkws rein dürfen
und das ist ein anderes problem also ich
kann euch tatsächlich hier nur probleme
aufzählen denn wir sind also über einen
grenzpunkt rein da können nur pkw rein
wir haben da allein so zwei stunden
gewartet auf der gegenüberliegenden
seite auch und an den stationen aber wo
die lkws rein und rausgehen ist das
ganze verkehrsaufkommen einfach noch
viel viel höher und dann dauert das noch
länger also vor uns waren ungefähr 20
pkw und das hat schon zwei stunden
gedauert jetzt kann man sich vorstellen
wenn sich da die lkws stauen letzten
mittwoch vor ein paar tagen waren es
beispielsweise
1100 die an den grenzen standen die
stehen hier also teilweise bis zu 50
stunden tage lang und mit den zügen ist
es dasselbe ich hab's angesprochen zu
wenig personal also es fehlt auch
einfach an den posten an den grenzposten
wo die lkw rein und raus können das
funktioniert nicht an jedem und da ist
man einfach nicht drauf eingestellt weil
also das getreide niemals in diesem
aufkommen so das land verlassen hat
alisa vielen dank für den moment
johannes sagt er kann uns jetzt wieder
besseren ist das so
im wunderbar
nochmal volles verständnis die akten
ukraine hat aktuell keine andere
möglichkeit auf den seeweg getreide zu
exportieren ist das richtig
das absolut richtig also zu 70 des
ukrainischen getreideexport laufen über
die häfen und die sind nach wie vor
blockiert hier vor der küste von odessa
das ist der letzte freihafen eigentlich
es gibt noch ein paar kleinere im
hinterland aber besser ist ihr
wichtigster größte habe und vor der
küste kreuzen russische kriegsschiffe
die man aus fuhr der ukrainischen
frachtschiffe verhindern der seeweg ist
außerdem vermint und ihr traut sich
keiner aus dem hafen raus und es geht
einfach gar nicht
präsident putin hat ja gesagt er wäre
bereit diese blockade zu lösen wenn
diese minen weg geräumt würden die die
ukraine gelegt hat wie erklärst du dir
das
also hier glaubt dem russischen
präsidenten wirklich absolut niemanden
es eine völlige verkehrung der tatsachen
hier heißt es die mindestens sich von
uns gelegt worden man hat ja gerade
gestern die einen ziemlich großen roms
gehört und namhafter ist eine mine
richtung stadt getrieben die wurde dann
kontrolliert gesprengt von den ukrainern
hier sagt man es sind die russen die den
seeweg verdient haben und das ist ein
mal wieder eine typische hügel von
wladimir putin um die ukraine zu
beschuldigen hier zu spielen ist
eigentlich genau andersrum es sei die
russen die blockieren würden und diese
minen legen und deswegen fordert man
hier eigentlich auch eine internationale
bereitstellung von kriegsschiffen um
einen korridor zu binden alle vorschläge
die aus russland kommen dass man jetzt
hier aus führen könnte man sei bereit
das also dass die ukraine ausführen kann
den trautmann überhaupt nicht denn man
hatte angst dass man die schiffe
ausführt dann kommen russische
kriegsschiffe und schnappen die einfach
weg also den russen traut man hier nicht
ein zentimeter mit dem weg die müssen
wir uns das vorstellen wenn die silos
dann irgendwann voll sind dann können
die landwirte ja auch nicht weiter
ernten wohin mit dem getreide was
passiert mit diesem getreide dass sie an
anderen teilen der welt gerade so
dringend benötigt wird
das ist tatsächlich eines der größten
probleme die silos sinnvoll und die neue
ernte steht bevor es gibt im moment
keine anderen auffangmöglichkeiten für
das getreide und das bedeutet dass das
getreide möglicherweise schlecht wird
deshalb wollen uns auch gesagt man muss
das behandeln damit er nicht irritieren
und bakterien reinkommen ich weiß aber
nicht wo man das machen kann und das
zweite ist das natürlich eine
katastrophe für die pharma hier den die
kriegen ja nur geld wenn sie das
verkaufen im moment ist das ein problem
das nicht im ansatz gelöst wird hier in
der ukraine alle fragen sich wie das
weitergehen soll und viele farmer haben
ja auch angst um ihre zukunft denn sie
wissen einfach nicht wohin mit dem
ganzen getreide das jetzt auf den
feldern steht und relativ weit im sommer
geerntet wird das problem dabei ist auch
mal versucht das jetzt länger auf den
feldern stehen zu lassen was aber dazu
führt dass das getreide sehr trocken
wird und wie die große angst besteht
dass die ernte verbrennt wenn es jetzt
zum bachelor kommt weil es nicht mehr
frisch genug ist sozusagen weil es
trocken ist und nicht rechtzeitig
abgeerntet wird aber der versuch ist es
sozusagen länger auf den feldern stehen
zu lassen in der hoffnung dass eine
lösung gefunden wird dann ist das auch
bereits schon darüber berichtet dass
russland wohl auch gezielt
landwirtschaftliche einrichtungen
angreift
also das ist ziemlich eindeutig also wir
sind hier viel unterwegs gewesen in den
ländlichen gebieten und wir haben immer
wieder gesehen wie raketen in feldern
eingeschlagen sind in auf bauernhöfen
eingeschlagen sind und das sind mit
sicherheit keine militärischen ziele
gewesen was dahintersteckt ist man wie
die bauern auch verunsichern das
vermutet man hier jedenfalls die bauern
verunsichern auch auf ihre felder
zurückzukehren wenn da überall minen und
raketen blieben dann können wir nicht
arbeiten wir haben trecker gesehen die
auf minen gefahren sind immer wieder
explodieren hier tatsächlich auch kühe
die auf nun laufen die angst der
menschen auf die felder zu gehen ist
riesengroß man braucht ihr
minensuchtrupp die über die felder gehen
bevor man überhaupt anfangen kann zu
ernst oder die tiere auf die weide zu
schicken also das sieht sehr sehr böse
aus wie die menschen hier und man
vermutet dass wladimir putin und seine
truppen angewiesen hat das ganz bewusst
zu machen um die landwirtschaft in der
ukraine zu zerstören vielen dank
johannes für den moment alisa ich würde
dich gerne noch mal fragen
du hast davon gesprochen dass versucht
wird die exporte auf die schiene zu
verlagern auf die straße wie kann das
funktionieren das sind ja auch einigen
strecken bahnstrecken straßen zerstört
war
das stimmt also vor zwei tagen hier bei
uns in lemberg also im umkreis hier im
westen der ukraine wurde auch die
bahnschiene die infrastruktur getroffen
von einem raketeneinschlag das passiert
also immer wieder wir haben heute aber
mit dem verkehrsministerium hier
gesprochen und die sagten schon und das
haben uns auch bauern bestätigt das auch
mitbekommen dass die in der ukraine hier
schon sehr sehr schnell immer wieder
daran arbeiten mit hochdruck das dann
auch wieder zu reparieren also das
passiert schon und quasi von der
ukrainischen seite wird schon auch
sichergestellt dass das dann relativ
schnell wieder zum fahren kommt dann
funktioniert und diese schienen
repariert werden das ist also
tatsächlich am ende des tages nicht das
größte problem das größte problem ist
das nadelöhr an den grenzen das größte
problem sind fehlende fahrer natürlich
der hohe sprit auch fehlende
infrastruktur und logistik einfach und
da braucht es ganz klar mehr personal da
gibt es wohl natürlich auch pläne und
gedanken zu polen hat er beispielsweise
gesagt sie wollen jetzt das personal an
den grenzposten erhöhen aber
gleichzeitig auch passiert das auch
nicht von heute auf morgen und da muss
man einfach sehen dass das ganze noch
schneller geht denn johannes hat das
angesprochen hier liegt die ernte in den
silos die silos sind voll aber die
nächste ernte wartet schon um 1 gefahren
zu werden und das größte problem hier
ist natürlich auch die zeit
und wenn du gerade beschreibt dieses
nadelöhr an der grenze da droht eine
hungersnot und gleichzeitig steht die
bürokratie im weg wie kann das sein
das fragen sich hier natürlich auch ganz
viele also die hungersnot die steht
natürlich den leuten auch in der welt
bevor wir uns im beitrag auch am anfang
gehört denn hier in der ukraine liegt
das korn und das will natürlich raus und
das kann einfach dadurch sein dass die
logistik eben noch nicht so hergestellt
ist wie man es bräuchte man muss sich
das so vorstellen dass einfach alles
über den seeweg gegangen sind man
arbeitet schon mit hochdruck natürlich
daran auch andere wege zu finden auch
beispielsweise über die moldau über
diesen weg sollen jetzt an drei häfen
wird da versucht dass man darüber auch
mehr ausschöpfen kann aber es scheitert
wirklich an dieser enormen menge und das
ist natürlich zum schier wahnsinnig
werden das ist ganz klar aber es sind
einfach ich habe sie alle aufgezählt so
so viele probleme dass das natürlich
nicht von heute auf morgen zu lösen ist
und gleichzeitig wird aber hier die zeit
immer knapper dass das getreide verdirbt
so so schlimm wie das ist natürlich
johannes ich hatte noch eine frage an
dich aus dem chat nach odessa alexander
fragt auf youtube könnte eine marine
mission im schwarzen meer die lösung
sein
alexander sagt er ist bei der marine
gewesen und sie hätten ähnliches während
eines embargos und der adria gemacht
also das ist genau das was sich die
ukrainische regierung wünscht und
vorstellt man hat immer wieder gesagt
man braucht amerikanische nato oder
blauhelmtruppen in im schwarzen meer
schiffe die dort das garantieren dass
die ukrainischen frachtschiffe ohne von
rosen bedrängt zu werden ausgeführt
werden können die das land also die die
helfen verlassen können aber danach
sieht es im moment nicht aus das ist
eine zentrale forderung ja und ich
glaube auch alexander dass das
sicherlich funktionieren würde aber
dafür müsste man kriegsschiffe hier ins
schwarze meer schicken der bosporus ist
blockiert erdogan lässt keine
kriegsschiffe soweit ich weiß in das
schwarze meer hinein fahren und das
würde einen sehr großen internationalen
kraftakt bedeuten nicht nur die türkei
zu überzeugen sondern auch russland
davon zu überzeugen dass diese
kriegsschiffe nicht hier einfahren um
russland irgendwie anzugreifen oder um
den krieg mit zu entscheiden dafür hat
russland natürlich angst wenn ihr auf
einmal amerikanische zerstörer und
fregatten auftauchen dass das
möglicherweise ein eingriff in diesen
krieg sein könnte und das finde
umgekehrt aber auch kein internationaler
beteiligt also keine die die nato möchte
das nicht die amerikaner möchte das
nicht weil man angst hat dann hier auf
einmal möglicherweise in einem
seegefecht mit den russen sollten die
dann doch zu schlagen wollen verwickelt
werden könnte und das würde eine
militärisch große auseinandersetzung
nach sich ziehen simon schreibt auf
youtube der krieg muss schnellstmöglich
beendet werden und das geht nur über die
diplomatie mann mussten mit russland
wieder reden bevor alles aus dem ruder
läuft johannes jetzt will ja die türkei
mit russland verhandeln über einen um
getreide korridor wie
erfolgsversprechend kann das sein
also es wird schon seit längerem
verhandelt zwischen der ukraine russland
der türkei und den vereinten nationen
soweit ich weiß da gab es gestern noch
meldungen da hat das russische
verteidigungsministerium verkündet dass
man jetzt eine lösung hat und ein
korridor bildet aber hier in der ukraine
wurde das erst mal gar nicht kommentiert
und dann hieß es das ist wieder nur
gerede wir können dem nicht vertrauen da
dass die vertrauensbasis ist völlig
zerstört putin hat so viel gelogen wenn
wir uns darauf jetzt einfach ein lassen
besteht die möglichkeit dass unsere
frachtschiffe wenn sie raus von von
russischen kriegsschiffen konfisziert
werden und abgeführt werden abgeschleppt
werden das machen wir auf gar keinen
fall also da fehlt es an vertrauen auf
beiden seiten und noch ist es nicht
soweit ist wird verhandelt auch die
ukraine weiß wie wichtig es ist auch für
die eigenen pharma dass das getreide das
alte getreide von den letzten hat der
aus den silos rauskommt damit das neue
rein kommt das heißt er ist ein enormer
druck aber auf der anderen seite will
man doch nicht auf jeden preis sich auf
putins aussage verlassen dazu hat man
viel zu schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
alisa und johannes ich danke euch ganz
herzlich für eure schilderungen und
erklärungen alles gute zu euch
ja die beiden haben uns ja gerade
geschildert wie schwierig die situation
in der ukraine ist wie gesagt im nahen
osten und in afrika droht eine
hungersnot
hilfsorganisationen sagen es ist fünf
vor zwölf und die sorge vor einer
hungerkatastrophe ist so groß dass der
vorsitzende der afrikanischen union der
senegalesische präsident max zahlen
heute nach russland gereist ist er hat
dort präsident putin in sotschi
getroffen und dringend darum gebeten die
ausfuhr blockade aufzuheben afrika sei
der situation völlig ausgeliefert sagte
wir fragen jetzt marcel kolb militär
ökonom guten abend genau da kommt ihr
fachgebiet ist die ökonomie des modernen
wirtschaftskrieges insofern können sie
uns mit sicherheit einiges erklären dazu
es gab jetzt gerade vor einer
viertelstunde eine
agenturmeldung dass putin bei genau
diesem treffen das leben gerade
dargestellt haben mit marquis allah
gesagt hat dass er bereit sei den export
von getreide aus der ukraine nach afrika
zu ermöglichen was was ist davon zu
halten
ja also sie sehen das ist eigentlich
eine gut inszenierte
schmierenkomödie die putin letztlich
natürlich in die hände spielt aber ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass man mal
grundsätzlich versteht wie der
welthandel mit nahrungsmitteln überhaupt
funktioniert und auch wie das verhältnis
ist von exporten zu eigenproduktion und
das erste was man wissen sollte ich mach
das mal am weizen fest ist dass die
meisten nahrungsmittel die in einem land
produziert werden auch dort gegessen
werden das heißt also
wir haben derzeit eine weltproduktion
von etwa 2.200 millionen tonnen an
getreide aber nur einen welthandel mit
ungefähr 400 millionen tonnen das heißt
also sie sehen aus wie werden im
wesentlichen dort gegessen wenn sie
produziert werden das beste beispiel
wäre ich ja nun geht es der proteste
weizen produzent der welt produziert
ungefähr 111 millionen tonnen von der
globalen weizenproduktion von 779
millionen tonnen aber diese 111
millionen die werden hauptsächlich in
indien selbst konsumiert das heißt also
wir haben ein extremes missverhältnis
oder oder eine extreme
ungleichverteilung zwischen produktion
und welthandel wenn wir jetzt anschauen
die gesamten weizenexporte der ukraine
das sind etwa 24 millionen tonnen wenn
sie das vergleichen mit dem 779
millionen tonnen der weltproduktion dann
kommen sie relativ schnell zu dem
schluss es gibt keine knappheit an
nahrungsmitteln auf der welt sie können
die gleiche rechnung durchführen für
reis für gerste für meist sie kommen
überall zum gleichen ergebnis das
problem ist ein anderes
es handelt sich nicht um ein problem der
menge sondern des preises weil es
einfach passiert ist aufgrund des
krieges ist das an den futures märkten
also dort wo die kontrakte gehandelt
werden auf künftige ernsten einfach
unglaubliche risikoprämien eingepreist
worden sind bei manchen
agrargütern haben wir preissteigerungen
um 200 und 250 prozent das heißt also es
handelt sich um einen preiseffekt und
wenn sie jetzt in afrika und auch da
muss man genau hinschauen welche länder
sind betroffen aber wenn sie jetzt eines
dieser länder sind das eben seine
nahrungsmittel teilweise oder ganz
importiert dann haben sie nur das
problem dass sie am weltmarkt plötzlich
mit sehr viel höheren preisen
konfrontiert worden sind also um das
ganz klar zu sagen die welt hat keine
hungerproblem es ist nicht so dass es
nicht genügend nahrungsmittel in der
welt gäbe sondern die nahrungsmittel von
die kontrakte auf künftige ernten sind
jetzt einfach sehr viel teurer geworden
und dass dieser preiseffekt das setzt
die länder unter druck es gibt genügend
andere exporteure in der welt
beispielsweise kanada oder australien
die auch sehr große mengen weizen
liefern könnten aber dieser weizen ist
jetzt natürlich viel teurer geworden und
das setzt länder eben wenn sie in afrika
least developed countries sind und nicht
viel geld haben natürlich stand unter
druck ok also ich bin halt kurz
zusammenfassen
arme länder haben dann einen
hungerproblem weil sie ein geldproblem
haben weil die weizenpreise so
explodiert sind aber ist das denn teil
von putins strategie auch eben über
explodierende preise dann eine eine
hungersnot auszulösen
also ich würde sagen
strategien nicht weil putin kontrolliert
weder die futures märkte noch das welt
angebot an nahrungsmitteln was wir aber
tun kann und auch jetzt sehr erfolgreich
leider er getan hat ist so eine
propaganda geschichte zu kontrollieren
nach dem motto ich habe die hand auf dem
welt getreide angebot und wenn ihr nicht
lieb zu mir seid oder wenn ihr nicht die
sanktionen und zurück nimmt dann kann
ich die welt verhungern lassen so und
wenn diese botschaft die natürlich
falsch ist aus sachlicher perspektive
wenn die nun aber aufgegriffen wird und
verbreitet wird über über twitter und
die medien und so weiter und genügend
leute daran glauben dann funktioniert
die geschichte und sie sehen jetzt eben
an besuch des senegalesischen
präsidenten wie gut die funktioniert
wenn sie jetzt ich bleibe mal ein
beispiel senegal wenn sie den mal
angucken der weniger produziert selbst
übrigens weizen also er importiert etwa
60 prozent seines bedarfs sowohl aus
russland als auch aus der ukraine und
wenn sie mal angucken und wieviel
handelt es sich da absolut ich habe das
vor der sendung nachgeschaut es sind 7
123 tonnen also im vergleich zur
weltproduktion eine absolut
vernachlässigbare menge aber sie sehen
jetzt wie das wirkt im fernsehen ja es
gibt jetzt so als würde der gesamte
senegal verhungern wenn nicht bald der
krieg aufhört und das ist schlichtweg
nicht der fall ich könnte jetzt auch
sagen im senegal wird vor allem reis
gegessen wenn wir über getreide reden
und das kommt aus indien und die
philippinen weizen ist eigentlich gar
nicht so wichtig aber dann kommen wir
jetzt in so in alle möglichen details
aber das wäre wichtig dass man das
zunächst mal versteht es ist also schon
ein gewisses zeichen von soll ich sagen
von schwäche oder von geringer vorhanden
das fähigkeit wenn man so was macht also
bei putin in moskau zu kreuze kriecht
und sagt bitte beliefere mich da gibt es
durchaus andere kanäle die man nutzen
können welche kämpfen das seien
ja in erster linie die frau also die
food and agriculture organization der
vereinten nationen es ist ja nicht so
dass in den listen kann jay ist vor
allem in afrika man kann in der
vergangenheit keine hungerkrisen oder
probleme mit nahrungsmitteln gehabt
hätte im gegenteil also wenn sie die
berichte der un wesen da tauchen
dieselben länder immer wieder auf es
sind teilweise probleme die wir seit
seit 20 jahren haben aber es gibt
entsprechende hilfsprogramme der un was
eben nicht existiert bislang ist eine
ein hochfahren dieser programme jetzt
auf die neuen globalen der gegebenheiten
das wäre aber problemlos möglich wenn
sie wenn sie für alle getreidesorten mal
die welt
lagerbestände zusammenzählen dann sind
wir bei ungefähr 850 millionen tonnen
also über alle getreidesorten zusammen
und das wäre mehr als genug um sämtliche
least developed countries auf jahrzehnte
hinaus
verlegen sie wenn ich unterbreche was er
aber jetzt das konkrete problem das in
der ukraine wie wir es eben gehört haben
auch tonnen getreide verrotten aktuell
nicht lösen würde ich würde gerne noch
mal mit ihnen auf diesen punkt eingehen
dass putin ja fordert dass der westen
die sanktionen aufheben soll und dann
löst er die
getreideexport blockade auf aber das
muss doch klar sein dass der westen das
nicht tun wird oder
ich weiß mittlerweile nicht mehr was
putin wirklich noch klar ist also ob er
selber an seine negative glaubt oder ob
er weiß dass das alles nur eine eine
inszenierung ist also natürlich ist das
ein ökonomisches problem für die ukraine
das ist schon so es ist aber nicht so
dass die ganze ernte er jetzt von heute
auf morgen verrottet also weizen finden
sie etwa zwei bis zweieinhalb jahre lang
wenn sie ihn entsprechend behandeln will
ihre korrespondenten haben das ja
erwähnt die haben ja auch gesagt dass
sie das die größten getreidespeicher
voll sind also wohin damit das ist ja
auch ein großes problem ja wohin damit
also gehen sie mal zum polnischen zoll
und sagen sie den polnischen zoll er
soll endlich mal mit der ukrainischen
regierung sagen wir mal auf zwölf monate
einen agrarfreihandel
vereinbaren damit sie diese logistischen
probleme an der grenze nicht haben also
den polnischen ukrainischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen sind ja im moment
so als gäbe ist gar keinen krieg also
sie haben jemand auch die regulierung
und die bürokratie von vor dem krieg was
sie einfach mal haben müssten ist diese
diese lästigen kontrollen an der
polnischen grenze abzuschaffen und sagen
okay jetzt auf einige monate machen wir
jetzt halt eine ausnahme und linken
diese weizen transporte durch ich halte
übrigens den schienen korridor also
diese idee das getreide über die züge
herauszubringen aus der ukraine für die
beste lösung oder sagen wir die
zweitbeste nach oben nachdem un programm
aber wie wir was machen sie sonst machen
also ihre komponenten richtig gesagt
über den seeweg das wird schwierig mit
dem abkommen von montreal dass die
türkei anwendet sie können nicht einfach
kriegstetten das schwarze meer einlaufen
lassen und nach allem was wir im krieg
gesehen haben würden sie putin jetzt
noch vertrauen wenn er sagt ich
etabliere hier irgendwelche sicheren
korridore wir haben mittlerweile
berichtet dass die russen das getreide
stehen aus demokratischen lagerhäuser
nach syrien zu schicken also da da wäre
ich doch sehr sehr vorsichtig aber der
westen wird sicher nicht das riesige
paket also genauer gesagt die sechs
sanktionspaket die es mittlerweile sehen
da aufheben um ukrainische seetransporte
zu gestalten sondern im gegenteil wenn
der westen etwas tun soll dann soll er
doch bitte auf polen einwirken dass die
dieser schienenkorridore möglichst
schnell auf die beine gestellte diesel
schreibt auf youtube putin verspricht
dem afrikanischen präsidenten die
blockade aufzuheben wer soll das denn
glauben also auch das was sie sagen es
gibt noch eine andere
frage vor von glücklich auf youtube kann
man nicht humanitäre lufträume schaffen
für den versand von weizen direkt in
besagte länder in denen es dringend
gebraucht wird
das problem ist halt weizen ist ein
massengut also ein sogenanntes schüttgut
und dafür bietet sich aus kosten- und
logistischen kunden eben das schiff an
als primäre premiere transports erst als
transportmittel luftfracht ist nun
leider sehr sehr teuer und auch wenn sie
an die ganzen flüge denken die dadurch
entstehen würden also sprich sie wollen
jetzt die vulkanische weizenernte per
flugzeug transportieren es wäre auch
nicht gerade umweltfreundlich das
stichwort emissionen das zu tun die
zweitbeste lösung für schüttgüter also
für große massen transporter ist nun mal
die eisenbahn und ich denke das sollte
sollte das mittel der wahl sein am
ehesten wenn wir also wenn wir diesem
flugzeug transportiert ethisch
diskutieren im ersten werden die
amerikaner in der lage ab dem flughafen
chefs über den die hilfslieferungen für
die ukraine hinein kommen also mit der
globe master oder mit der c-17 das zu
versuchen aber ich glaube nicht dass sie
da er das nötige volumen
zusammenbekommen würden eine
hungerkatastrophe in afrika könnte eine
weitere welle von flüchtenden nach
europa auslösen ist das auch teil der
strategie von putin das dass er das mit
einkalkuliert
ja ich weiss nicht also vielleicht
träumt ihn davon dass das passieren
könnte oder will das verkaufen als
geschichte ich glaube das nicht das ist
übrigens der negativ dass sie häufig so
von rechts konservativer seite hören
nach dem motto afrika sitzt auf
gepackten koffern und wartet nur darauf
hier so aus vor dem hunger zu fliehen
und nach europa anzuwenden also man muss
eines man sehen afrikanische migration
ist vor allem binnenmigration das heißt
also die leute wandern denn sie waren
dann von einem afrikanischen land in ein
anderes also von berlin beispielsweise
entlang der westafrikanischen küste aber
sicher nicht direkt nach europa ich
denke dass das ist ein sehr sehr
konstruierter dialog der auch mit den
ökonomischen realitäten nichts zu tun
hat aber selbst wenn wir daran glauben
die beste möglichkeit so etwas zu
verhindern
hypothetisch gesprochen wäre wenn die un
größere hilfslieferungen einfach in
diese länder schicken würde um
kurzfristig eine stabilisierung
durchzuführen also die lager sind da wie
gesagt 850 millionen tonnen haben wir in
den vorräten in allen getreidesorten die
schiffe sind da es müsste sich nur eben
jemand finden der es organisiert wenn
ich das noch sagen darf der vorsitzende
der un generalversammlung abdullah ii er
hat das am 26 mai in einer rede selbst
gesagt hat wörtlich gesagt wir haben
keine nahrungsmittel in problemen in der
welt wir haben genügend nahrungsmittel
um alle zu ernähren was wir haben ist
ein preis problem und ein logistisches
problem und da müssen wir ansetzen das
preis problem lösen indem wir die menge
auf den markt werfen oder indem wir die
leute direkt versorgen das heißt die
züge los schiffen die schiffe
losschicken und das logistische problem
das wissen wir dadurch dass wir eben
solche korridore möglichst frei geben
also dass wir mit der mit der bürokratie
an die wir uns alles so gewöhnt haben
einfach mal schluss machen und sagen
macht die tore auf lasst die ernte
endlich raus kommen ja das hat alissa
jung ja vorhin eindrücklich geschildert
vielleicht noch eine letzte frage von
philipp auf youtube ist dann auch in
europa mit einem weiteren ansteigen der
lebensmittelpreise zu rechnen
ja das hat allerdings andere gründe also
das liegt nicht daran dass jetzt die
organischen exporte blockiert sind
europa ist selbst der größte
weinproduzent des planeten also wenn sie
gegebenen produktion zusammen nehmen das
problem ist vielmehr aufgrund der
gestiegenen energiepreise steigen
natürlich auch die produkte die die
preise für vorprodukte und auch die
transportkosten und
diese inflation der energie also von von
öl gas transportkosten und so weiter
übersetzt sich jetzt gerade in eine
inflation der lebensmittelpreise
also das hat nichts mit der lage in der
ukraine sondern das hat mit der
angespannten lage auf den energiemärkten
zu tun also da gilt genau das gleiche
wenn man die installation und auch die
lebensmittelpreise zu hause in den griff
bekommen will dann muss man die
energiemärkte entspannen das heißt also
mehr öl angebot auf den markt werfen zb
man andere produzentenländer wieder an
ins boot holt indem man das atom
abkommen mit dem iran beispielsweise
endlich mal ab schließt aber
mit der ukraine situation hat es direkt
nichts zu tun ferk ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für ihre erklärungen und ihrer
analyse und wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend
im casino danke ja und ich wünsche euch
einen schönen abend noch möchte noch
kurz zum schluss einen kommentar von
sigrid kramer auf youtube vorlesen denn
sie schreibt super stream dankeschön und
sie schreibt vor allem wäre schön wenn
man mit diplomatie den krieg beenden
könnte in diesem sinne ich wünsche euch
einen schönen abend und schöne feiertage
habe eine gute zeit bis bald